Jimmy travel normally during the
holidays is a nightmare but when you're
canceling thousands of flights things
can get pretty crazy in the airports
which everybody just needs to behave
right
um I I do consider myself a travel
expert because I do I travel a lot for
stand up and Jenny's family is in Ohio
the true superpower to getting through
something like this is really to be calm
you've got to be calm and you've got to
just play the hand you're dealt like the
travel gods are in charge here be it
with weather be it with delays God made
airport bars for a reason use them it's
probably the only time in your life
you'll watch CNN but you got to be calm
just take it easy and you'll get there
when you get there it's so much more
important to stay safe and just don't
freak out that was a sincere message
from Jimmy phela I kept waiting for the
hands
I'm an adult sometimes
Christmas sucks that's no fun especially
if you're trying to see your family
right yeah it is you know as I look at
the snow I grew up in the snow belt in
the Southern Tier of New York so I mean
I was never able to wear a Halloween
costume without a winter coat because it
was always snowing in Elmira always so I
mean this doesn't freak me out in fact I
been in airports where they don't fly
when there's like a half an inch and you
want to jump across and strangle not the
woman no the man at the desk with the
pilot like what do you mean you can't
fly out of here but um I agree I think
that today Jimmy are right I think
everybody after the pandemic is really
short on on any kind of um you know they
just don't have any any belief or any
any what's the word I'm looking for yeah
and they just get angry and people are
fighting with each other all the time
you can't the people behind the desk are
only doing what they can do for you my
concern is the people who get into cars
and drive and uh then take take a lot of
risks because especially if they don't
know how to drive in the snow that's a
problem yeah Jessica I was actually
talking to a friend in Iowa today some
friends of Minnesota and like are you
guys okay it's going to be negative 30
there and they're like oh it'll be back
and in the regular 30s by the end of the
weekend no big deal yeah
yeah I was in Chicago during a polar
vortex five years I suggest you smaller
Vortex
no need a block Jimmy did it B Block
gaming
um and I was out of my mind freaked out
I had like all new gear for it and
everyone who lived there was a family
like I was completely insane they were
like this is just two days yeah like
just go inside have a drink yeah we'll
reassemble well and also people like a
white Christmas right so it will be
pretty but it is sad that it's the first
holiday or this Thanksgiving and then
Christmas after the pandemic where
people feel ready to go out there right
they're seeing their family sometimes
for the first time since all of this or
taking a much needed vacation and now
yeah if if seriously if you're liberal
like red States we had a full blog
really if you saw how hard we Christmas
last year yeah the pandemic's been over
for a while I've gone away in my defense
my liberal defense but you know I get
you all right